now I want you to keep that in your mind
as we now consider I'm ready to give you
the heading now okay where are we going
to go from here we're going to consider
the same idea with graphs but with
circles and semicircles okay now just
put your pairs now for a minute
circles and semicircles and put your
pens down for a minute just need to wave
a flag for something
I'll just want to air everyone's ready
okay cool this next part I'm about to
show you on this new and if you haven't
drawn it in it I want to stop talking
for this some sentence you can also do
this what I want to show you here I'm
going to go through quite quickly
because it's something covered in the
year ten five point three course now I'm
very conscious of the fact that that
means several people in this room
haven't met this before this is gonna be
the first time you meet it so you know
the first time you learn anything you're
like wow this is quite hard but in like
the second and the third and the fourth
time you are more comfortable with this
all right this is part of why I like if
you experience it as this is really hard
and confusing that's why five point
three is rep listed as a an assumed
knowledge for the extension one course
okay so I'm just waving that flag now
this is about to be conceptually
difficult but you need this to progress
to the next part okay so having said
that if you have it already go ahead and
draw a new set of axes make this one a
bit bigger than the previous ones this
is all review stuff but this one bigger
ten by ten is a good size ten my tens a
good size
does anyone need these graphs on the
left can I get rid of them now you're
still going I'll let you take a picture
this
[Music]
tell me when you're ready resting
perfect nice okay excellent so you've
got your new set of axes right and what
we're all going to draw on to this
because the heading is circles and
semicircles what I'd like you to draw
onto your nice big luxurious set of axes
is draw a nice big circle that takes up
most of what's going on here so I'm
gonna draw mine by the way um you didn't
know that we're going to do this today
so you probably did not bring a pair of
compasses with you and don't worry I
don't have a pair of compasses either my
big tip for you is we're going to draw a
circle and it's going to be centered on
the origin so I'm going to mark out some
equal spots like so and I'm pretty bad
at drawing the whole circle all at once
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
draw the quadrants because I can do them
reasonably easily and if I were you I
would actually rotate my page around
because your head if you're right-handed
or left-handed there's an arc that's
quite easy for your hand to draw and
then there are other arcs that feel
awkward and backward you can move your
page I can't move the whiteboard so go
ahead and move your page around so that
you can draw it nicely and easily okay
okay so we gonna get that all right now
this guy here like I said I'm gonna move
through this bit a little bit quickly
this particular circle that we're
drawing it's not just any circle it has
a name this guy is called the unit
circle now the reason it has that name
is the size of this circle is that it
has a radius of one unit hence unit
circle and you can see it's centered
right here on the origin okay now what
we want to unpack is what is the
equation of this thing we know the
equation of parabola we know the
equation of a hyperbola not just what is
that equation but also why is that the
equation okay so let's develop it
together here's what I want to suggest
you do every point on this circle right
I I want its coordinates to satisfy the
equation of the circle okay so I'm gonna
pick a point I'm gonna pick one over
here in the first quadrant over here
first quadrant positive positive right
and what I'd like you to do with me is
draw the radius from the center up to
this point okay
now what I can say about this point is
that if it lies you know somewhere on
the circle right it could be anywhere I
can't say oh this might be I don't
actually know numbers for these corners
I've asked you to draw it somewhere I
don't know where you've drawn it but it
will have an x value and it will have a
y value okay so I'm literally just gonna
call that point X comma Y its x value is
X its Y values Y not very original I
know but I'm gonna use that to build the
equation okay
now just keep your pen in your hand on
the same spot on your page but just look
up momentarily because you need to see
this part actually happen okay I don't
want you to look down and then look up
you're like where did that come from
okay so eyes on the board for a second
I'm going to put on a right angle
triangle inside this diagram okay and
I'm gonna build it off of this radius
watch carefully see this x value here it
means from the origin go to the right X
units okay that's like if this was three
for example it means go from here and go
one two three right so to go from here
to the right like so see this little
interval I just drew its width
or its length I should say is X units do
you agree with that so that's X okay
keep your eyes on board still one more
piece to draw and then I've got the
triangle this Y means from the origin go
up wide units right so if it was like
eight I'd go one two three four five six
seven eight I climb up so this vertical
interval here is why isn't it that's
it's like okay you can go ahead and draw
that that's a really important piece so
you know where these came from right
I've got a right-angled triangle here
because this is horizontal this is
vertical so it's going to be right
angled and how wide is it X units how
tall is it y unis are you following with
me now I said this is not just any
circle it's the unit circle so you
actually can tell me what the hypotenuse
is which is the missing piece it's one
right
okay now what's great about this is this
X in this why you've probably drawn
yours in a similar spot to mine but I
could have drawn it over here or over
here or over here right and I could
still draw a right angle triangle to
that point right and whatever right
angle triangle you've got what's the
piece of knowledge that we always apply
in right angle triangles back think back
to you right right we call it Pythagoras
theorem right I can stay a relationship
between all these sides using Pythagoras
theorem he's hungry Sator squares of the
two shorter sides right that's a
x-squared plus y-squared they should
equal the square of the hypotenuse right
which in this case is one and that there
I'm gonna underline it because so
important that there is the equation of
the unit circle okay now what if this
wasn't unit circle what if it was bigger
okay suppose I had a circle which didn't
have radius one suppose I was radius
like four for example okay you know just
imagine inflating this a little bit okay
the X is still gonna be X the Y is still
gonna be Y but what will change okay now
think carefully yeah the if I made the
radius of this circle four then when I
go to Pythagoras theorem this one is
actually 1 squared isn't it so if the
radius were four would be 4 squared
right
if the radius were 183 this would be 183
squared whatever it happens to be okay
so this is the unit circle but
underneath this I'd love you to write
this with me more generally right if I
don't just have the unit circle with a
specific radius if I think in general
terms for any size circle right it will
be x squared plus y squared equals you
told me 1 squared or 4 squared or a
hundred and eighty-three squared it's
just the it's just the radius squared
what's the usual letter that we give to
the radius R R isn't used for too much
other stuff R squared x squared plus y
squared equals R squared is the equation
are the circle with okay now every
circle has two pieces of information
that define it we already just said one
right there's the radius okay so it's
the equation of a circle with radius R
but the other piece of information we
need is where is this circle right now
do you member when we had a look at the
parabolas and then we had a look at the
hyperbolas right so where is the center
of this it's at the origin right where
radius R and Center 0 0 . ok